Mr. President,
Roshei Yeshiva, worthy
rabbis, ladies and gentlemen.
On behalf of Yeshiva University, it is my
privilege to welcome you this evening to
the third and final lecture of the three
lectures comprising the Benjamin Gottesman
Presidential Lectures in Jewish Thought.
It is a special delight to acknowledge
this evening the presence of Mr. and
Mrs. Benjamin Gottesman and family.
On behalf of all of us, I
welcome Mr. and Mrs. Gottesman
and wish to express publicly to
them our deepest gratitude for
helping make this evening possible.
Tonight's lecture is also the Mrs. Tanya
Soloveitchik and Dr. Samuel Soloveitchik
Memorial Lecture, adding even more
significance to what, in any event,
is a spiritual and intellectual feat
without parallel in this generation,
namely, a public address by the Rav.
No introduction can do justice
to our speaker this evening.
One can, however, render kavod la'Torah.
And I can think of no more appropriate
way to do so than to call upon the
President of Yeshiva University, Rabbi Dr.
Norman Lamm, who will introduce the Rav.
President Lamm.
Kevod Maran Ha'Rav Shlita,
distinguished guests,
members of the Gottesman family,
students, ladies and gentlemen.
Actually, as Dean Leiman pointed
out, these words of introduction are
superfluous; they're unnecessary.
Indeed, it's rather presumptuous for
anyone to introduce the Rav to an assembly
of lomdei Torah and shochrei Torah, but
there's something special about this
year's drashah, about this year's lecture.
"V'kidashtem es shnas ha'chamishim
shanah," we have to sanctify the 50th
year, the Jubilee year, and this is the
Jubilee year for the Soloveitchik family's
connection with Yeshiva University.
It was in 1929 that HaGaon Reb
Moshe Soloveitchik,
zecher tzaddik livrachah,
came here to teach.
And it is some 38 years, ad me'ah v'esrim
shanah, that the Rav has been marbitz
Torah b'rabim here at Yeshiva University.
And therefore, this is a special occasion,
and that is my excuse, my apologia for
daring to presume upon the Rav and upon
you to introduce him, albeit very briefly.
The Zohar tells us, in a most fascinating
passage, about Rabbi Shimon bar
Yochai on the day that he passed away.
"B'ha'hee yoma d'ba Rabbi Shimon
l'istalek min alma," the day that
Rabbi Shimon was about to depart from
the world, "va'hava mesader miloy,"
he prepared himself, arranged his
affairs, and "iskansu chavraya l'gabei
Rabbi Shimon," the colleagues, the
chachamim, the students, disciples
came to pay their respects to their
teacher, "va'hava malya beisa," the
house was full, there was no room to
move, "zakif Rabbi Shimon eino va'chama
d'ismalya beisa" -- can you hear me?
Rabbi Shimon -- too much.
Rabbi Shimon looked about and saw
that the house was filled, whereupon,
"bachah Rabbi Shimon," he began to
weep, and he said there was another
time that I was very, very sick.
And at that time, only one person
came to visit me, "hava Rabbi
Pinchas ben Ya'ir kamai," the great
disciple of Rabbi Shimon, Rabbi
Pinchas ben Ya'ir came to visit him.
And at that time, "is'char esha mi'kamai,"
he was enveloped in fire, "u'mei'almin la
ispasak," and that flame never left him.
"V'hashta," but now, I
see something different.
Now, I see that "ispasak." Now,
I see that the fire has left.
There is no longer any fire, "v'ha
ismalei beisa," but the house is full.
Rabbi Shimon wept when he saw
that he now had great popularity,
but there was no longer a fire.
And he preferred the is'char
esha to the ismalya beisa.
In the contest between contents
and fame, between passion and
popularity, the Zohar clearly chooses
is'char esha over ismalei beisa.
Better depth and content and
profundity than mere popularity.
I mention this because ashreinu u'mav tov
chelkeinu, how fortunate are we, not only
in this yeshiva, but in all the city, in
all the country, indeed, in all the world
-- we have here distinguished guests from
Israel as well -- that this last Yovel,
this last Jubilee, this last half century,
and especially under the tutelage and
leadership of the Rav, the last 38 years,
we have not had to choose, because we have
been blessed with both in the person of
the Rav, is'char esha and ismalei beisa.
We have is'char esha, the Rav's
depth, his gaonus, his ever-growing
creativity, which are legend.
And at this point, kol ha'mosif
gorei'a, I will say no more.
And at the same time, ismalei
beisa, the recognition by a very
grateful public, especially we of
Yeshiva University, who are all of
us, myself included, his talmidim.
Was his talmid, is his talmid
and hopes to remain his disciple
for many, many years to come.
Our prayer for the Rav is u'mei'almin
la ispasek, that he may continue
to be our teacher, to instruct
us, guide us, and enlighten us for
120 years.
Thank you very much.
I saw you have the mic and there
is an echo, there's feedback.
It's impossible to hear.
The topic is the
Haftarot, which we read on the
Shabbatot between Passover and Shavuos.
I would like to analyze a few
Haftarot and find the common
link or the common denominator
between the Haftarah
and the Parshas Ha'Yom.
The portion of Prophets
we read on the Shabbatot, on the
Sabbath, of the Shabbatot ha'shanah and
holidays, this portion is supposed to
address itself to an aspect which was
mentioned in the parshah,
in the kri'as ha'parshah.
Maimonides distinctly
and explicitly mentioned that the
Haftarah should always concern itself
with a motif
which we found in the
parshah during the kri'ah.
at the end of his siddur, he says,
m'ein ha'parshah, a Maftir
must treat a topic which
was already mentioned
by the parshah.
In other words, there is a common
denominator -- a requirement for
a common denominator, for a common
topic or motif in the parshah,
parshas ha'yom and in the Haftarah.
Let me say -- and
you know it, you don't need my
statement -- that it is not always
easy, it's not always simple
to find similarity, let alone identity of
themes in the Haftarah and in the parshah.
It's very difficult sometimes.
At times, we are simply baffled
by the choice of a particular
Haftarah, which prima facie
has absolutely nothing in common
with the parshah.
In such cases, an in-depth
analysis is indispensable.
As a matter of fact, lately, I simply
-- as it's just curiosity, perhaps.
It's just curiosity on my part,
inquisitiveness, but I have tried
in many cases to find this common
denominator in certain parshiyos
and the corresponding Haftaros.
In some, I have been very successful.
Some I could not find.
In some, I couldn't find the common
denominator, and I plead ignorance.
It happened so that in Vayikra, lately,
while listening to the Haftarah recited
by the Maftir, my thoughts were centered
about this common motif or denominator
in the parshah and the Haftarah.
And I arrived at certain
conclusions and which I would
like to share with you tonight.
And somehow, it's a nice
service or it is a davar b'ito,
because the first part of my
lecture will revolve about
Yerushalayim and kedushas Yerushalayim.
Tomorrow night is Yom Yerushalayim.
Is it so, or you have forgotten?
It is, I believe.
We have Mr. Corner [ph].
Isn't tomorrow night Yom Yerushalayim?
May I add
that the results of such an
investigation, such an analysis
in the depths -- in-depth
are extremely gratifying.
We gain insights -- new insights
into the parshah and the Haftarah
At times, one sentence suffices
to establish the unity of motifs
in the parshah and the Haftarah.
One sentence.
At times, one word.
Whenever we detect
the common motif in the parshah
and the Haftarah, we feel that a new light
-- in cases like that, a new, bright light
was cast upon the whole
parshah and the whole Haftarah.
Permit me to protect -- to present to you
two analytical studies.
Whether I'll be able to present
to you the second, I don't know.
It depends upon the clock, and I can't
see the clock here because of the lights.
And be careful, I mean, one takes a
risk if he comes into a hall where
I'm lecturing without a watch.
But anyway, the first one, I hope,
im yirtzeh Hashem, to conclude.
Yom Yerushalayim is
associated with the first one.
So, in Eretz Yisrael even may stay
at least [inaudible].
Permit me to present you
two analytical studies
embracing
several Haftaros we just finished reading.
The first study will concern
itself with four Haftaros.
Acharei Mos, Kedoshim,
Behar, Bechukosai.
We just read them.
Four Haftaros.
The second one, I hope I'll
have time to present to you,
is concerned
with Emor and Tazria-Metzora.
There is topical unity in the Haftarot
of Acharei Mos,
Kedoshim, Behar u'Bechukosai.
There is also topical unity, thematic
unity in the Haftarot of Emor and Tazria.
May I ask for Chumashim?
Do you have a Chumash?
It's too heavy.
I wish to start with the
Haftaros of Acharei Mos and Kedoshim.
What Haftarah
would I choose
for Acharei Mos and Kedoshim if
the choice had been left to me?
Of course,
I would say that if the choice had been
left to me, I would have chosen, selected,
two Haftarot.
For Acharei Mos, the Haftarah in
Yechezkel, Siman Chaf-Beis, 22.
"Va'yehi devar Adoshem elai leimor.
V'atah ben adam ha'sishpot
ha'sishpot es ir ha'damim,"
thou, son of man, would you sit in
judgment over the city of blood,
bloodshed, "v'hodatah es kol to'avoseha,"
and you'll inform the people of
the city about all the abominations
they committed.
It is most fitting for the Parshas Acharei
Mos because the Parshas Acharei Mos, the
last parshah, particularly, is concerned
with sex sins, with chet arayos and
also sheficus damim, bloodshed,
avodah zarah, molech.
I mean, it would be a proper
Haftarah to be recited on the
Shabbat of Acharei Mos and Kedoshim.
Kedoshim, I would recite a
similar Haftarah also from Yechezkel,
but treating the same topic.
"Vayehi devar Adoshem elai leimor.
Ben adam daber el ziknei Yisrael.
Ha'sishpot osam," will you sit in judgment
over them, "ha'sishpot ben adam es to'avos
avosam," will you sit in judgment over
them because of the abominations which
their parents or their ancestors were
engaged in or committed.
Those are the proper Haftaros.
As a matter of fact, in many Chumashim,
they are printed, those Haftaros.
In many shuls, in many batei knessios,
I discovered that still those two
Haftaros are being recited and read,
each one on its respective Shabbat.
Chaf on Acharei Mos,
Chaf-Beis on Kedoshim.
The Rambam, in his siddur, where he lists
all the Haftaros, also has for Acharei
Mos and Kedoshim two
Haftaros from Yechezkel.
There was no problem.
However,
there are many communities, particularly
Lithuanian, many, many communities,
and also many poskim
who recommended that the
Haftaros be replaced, the Haftaros from
Yechezkel be replaced by a Haftarah
from Amos, from the first prophet.
And instead of the Haftarah
dealing with the chet arayos, we
should read the portion from the
prophecy by Amos on both Shabbatot,
on Kedoshim and Acharei Mos.
And in a leap year -- if the year
is plain, so you read Acharei
Mos-Kedoshim at one time, so you
read Ki'vnei Kushiyim only once.
However, if the year is a leap year,
and Kedoshim and Acharei Mos are
separated from each other, so then
according to the minhag Lita, and
in accordance with many opinions
of poskim, gedolei Acharonim,
you read Ki'vnei Kushiyim twice;
on Shabbos of Acharei Mos, as well
as on the Shabbos of Kedoshim.
"Ha'lo ki'vnei Kushiyim atem
li Bnei Yisrael ne'um Adoshem
ha'lo es Yisrael he'eleisi mei'eretz
Mitzrayim u'Phlishtiyim mi'Kaftor
va'Aram mi'Kir."  We don't understand the relationship
of that portion of that prophecy
to Acharei Mos, to the laws
and halachos formulated
in the parshah of Acharei Mos or Kedoshim.
There is no similarity
at all between the
Haftarah and the parshiyos.
What is the reason, actually?
What is the reason that we replaced
the Haftaros from Yechezkel
with a Haftarah of Amos?
Of course, there is no mystery.
I mean, the answer is very simple.
At least the first answer is simple.
Then, another question arises, and we'll
have difficulty in solving this question.
There is no mystery at all.
There is a Baraisa in Megillah,
at the end of Megillah,
as well as in Mesechet Sofrim,
which quotes the opinion of Rabbi Eliezer.
Rabbi Eliezer says,
"Ein maftirin b'to'avos Yerushalayim,"
you should not recite the prophecies about
to'avos, the abominations of Yerushalayim,
"kol ikar," you don't mention them at all.
Neither for Acharei Mos, nor for Kedoshim.
We shouldn't.
"Ma'aseh b'echad" -- in Mesechet Sofrim,
as well as in the Gemara in Megillah, it
says, "Ma'aseh b'echad," it happened that
some individual, "haya korei lema'alah
m'Rabbi Eliezer," he was probably on
the second floor, Rabbi Eliezer
was on the street floor.
"Lema'alah m'Rabbi Eliezer," I
mean, geographically, as far as in
spatial terms, he was above Rabbi
Eliezer, "b'to'avos Yerushalayim,"
he recited the Maftir for Acharei
Mos or Kedoshim,
the Haftarah from To'avos
Yerushalayim from Yechezkel.
"Amar lo Rabbi Eliezer," so Rabbi
Eliezer told him, "reika," fool, "ad
sh'atah bodek b'to'avos Yerushalayim,"
you are so interested to indict
Yerushalayim of all crimes, "tzei u'vdok
b'imach," investigate your maternal
background, the family tree.
So, the Mesechet Sofrim says,
"U'matzo b'imo sh'hee pesulah," and
they found some p'sul as far
as the mother was concerned.
True, the Gemara in Megillah says,
"L'afukei mi'd'Rabbi Eliezer," the
halachah is not like Rabbi Eliezer.
That's what the Gemara in Megillah
says, but Mesechet Sofrim didn't say it.
Mesechet Sofrim quoted Rabbi
Eliezer, and apparently,
because he's in full
agreement with Rabbi Eliezer.
This means that according to Mesechet
Sofrim, is the halachah like
Rabbi Eliezer?
So, since the halachah is
like Rabbi Eliezer, so the two
Haftaros from Yechezkel, Chaf or
Chaf-Beis, are ruled out and they
are replaced by another Haftarah,
namely, K'vnei Kushiyim from Amos.
And as I said before, and we are
so careful and meticulous about
it that in a leap year, we read
the Haftarah of Amos twice.
Only a few Haftaros are read and
reread during the year, during the
annual cycle, but here it stopped.
A plain Haftarah is
recited for Acharei Mos and the
same is recited for Kedoshim.
Of course, we have accepted Rabbi
Eliezer's opinion that a Jew who
bought Maftir for $25 has no right to
criticize Jerusalem.
He has no right to repeat the
words of the Navi, of the Prophet.
And he should not charge Yerushalayim
with the Maftir, with crime, great sins
and transgressions and abominations.
He has no right.
The question here -- now, I mean, if
you could state the question, so that's
why we have replaced the Haftaros
of Achrei Mos-Kedoshim as far as the
nevuah of Yechezkel is concerned.
We don't recite it.
Fine.
Yeah, but there is still a question,
I mean, I haven't answered.
Why Amos?
Correct.
Chazal, Chachmei Yisrael could've chosen
or selected another Haftarah which
has some similarity to the parshiyos
ha'Torah, which had
something in common with the
parshiyos ha'Torah, with the kri'a.
We have chosen the
Haftarah of the first Navi,
Amos, which, prima facie, at first glance,
there's absolutely no relationship to
whatever the Torah has formulated in
Acharei Mos and Kedoshim, not at all.
At first glance, not a single sentence
unites Amos with the parshiyos
Kedoshim and Acharei Mos in the Torah.
The answer, I believe, is obvious.
It's not difficult.
Both sidros -- that means
Acharei Mos and Kedoshim
-- told the people something
which frightened them.
They addressed to the
people for the first time
since they left Mitzrayim, for the first
time, something frightening, horrifying.
Namely, what?
That there is a possibility, and perhaps not
only a possibility but a probability
or perhaps a certainty, that in
the future, they'll lose the land
and they will be exiled from
their ancestral land
into an endless, bleak
and dreary galut.
There is a reality,
which we call galut, that was
disclosed to the people in Acharei
Mos and Kedoshim for the first time.
The Torah says for the first time
-- later, the Torah repeated this warning
of what the Acharei Mos-Kedoshim -- the
people to whom Acharei Mos-Kedoshim
was revealed through Moshe, by Hakadosh
Baruch Hu through Moshe, were taken aback.
What did they hear?
They heard a few sentences, which
they did not understand a word and
they got frightened, horrified.
What happened?
"Ki es kol ha'to'eivos ha'eil,"
all those abominations, "asu
anshei ha'aretz asher lifneichem,"
were committed by the people of
the land who preceded your coming
to the land, "va'titma ha'aretz,"
and the land became defiled.
"V'lo saki ha'aretz
es'chem," and the land
should not vomit you out,
cast you out.
This is in Acharei Mos,
Vayikra Chaf-Teis, Chaf-Cheis.
Then in Kedoshim,
"U'shmartem es kol chukosai v'es kol
mishpatai va'asisem osam v'lo saki
ha'aretz," the same expression, the same
idiom, "v'lo saki ha'aretz es'chem," the
land will not throw you up, vomit you out.
It's a very strange word.
"Asher ani meivi es'chem shamah la'sheves
bah," to which I brought you in order to
live there for many, many, many years.
But should you commit those abominations,
so the land will simply shake you off.
As a matter of fact,
the Torah emphasizes that exile
from the land, or departure from the
land, in such a case, is a natural
phenomenon, not a penalty.
It is a phenomenon which
can be explained in
terms of cause and effect.
In causal terms, it could be understood.
It's not a special onesh imposed
upon the Jewish people, but it is
an -- it is a result of certain
behavior on the part of the people.
It is almost -- I mean, it fits
into the scheme of causality,
of cause and effect.
The land in words -- the land
does not tolerate immorality,
particularly immorality of
arayos and murder and bloodshed.
And it casts off the people who defile
themselves with such abominable deeds.
The way Rashi says, a prince with
a very delicate digestive system
will throw up if he'll be fed
food which is slightly spoiled.
Eretz Yisrael is a very delicate,
a very tender land.
It does not tolerate every aveirah.
It does not tolerate it.
It shakes them off.
You don't have to be punished for that.
It's simply the soil.
The particles of the soil
shake off every aveirah.
Rashi says, "Mashal l'ben
melech sh'he'echiluhu
davar ma'us sh'ein omed
b'mei'av u'meki'o kach Eretz
Yisrael einah mekayemes aleiha ovrei
aveirah." This is what Rashi says.
Like the prince who throws up if he
was fed something which was spoiled or
not the best or finest quality, because
he has a delicate digestive system,
so is Eretz Yisrael very sensitive.
Certain aveiros in chutz
la'aretz are differently assessed
than they would have
been in Eretz Yisrael.
Eretz Yisrael not as a ben melech but
a bas melech, very, very delicate,
very tender, very meticulous.
And galus is not a punishment.
It is the natural consequence of cheit.
That's what Rashi wanted to explain.
Nu?
So what?
And this the people
heard for the first time.
They heard that Eretz Yisrael
casts off, casts out sinners
or those who defile themselves
and defile the land
with their deeds.
So, wouldn't you say that the Chachamim
who actually dealt with this problem
of a Haftarah to choose the proper
Haftarah for Acharei Mos and Kedoshim
faced -- what shall I say -- a dilemma?
There were two possibilities.
One possibility is that the topic,
the theme of Kedoshim and Acharei Mos
should be, I mean, the laws pertaining
to arayos, to avodah zarah, to murder.
In Kedoshim, the laws pertaining
to Shabbos, to Kibud Av va'Em.
They could have
found such a prophecy or a portion
which would correspond, which would run
parallel to those basic laws which are
mentioned in Kedoshim or Acharei Mos.
Rashi, at the beginning of
Kedoshim, says this parshah includes
"gufei Torah," the very tenets
of our Torah.
So, it was quite possible, I mean,
to choose some chapter in Isaiah or
in Yechezkel or any other book of
Prophets which would correspond,
would run parallel to
the gufei Torah which
were formulated in Kedoshim
as well as in Emor.
There's another -- this is one
alternative, one possibility, but the
Chachamim had another possibility,
namely, to declare the central theme
of Acharei Mos and Kedoshim
is
galus.
The central theme consists in this
sentence: "V'lo saki ha'aretz es'chem."
We have the Maftir has got to react
to that theme, to the theme of
galus, which was new, something
new and incomprehensible to them.
The Chachamim had the choice either
to prefer the gufei Torah and declare
them as the central theme of Kedoshim,
and then fashion the Haftarah in
accordance with the gufei Torah.
"V'lo sechakashu v'lo
seshakeru. V'lo sishavu bi'shmi
la'shaker." Important mitzvos.
"Ish imo v'aviv tira'u
v'es Shabbsosai tishmoru.
Lo salin pe'ulas sachir it'cha ad boker.
V'ahavta l'rei'acha kamocha.
V'yareisa Adoshem Elokecha." Those
laws, tenets, principles of morality,
the basic principles of morality,
could have become the central theme
of Kedoshim, and the Haftarah would
have been fashioned in accordance with
those principles, would correspond to
those -- with those principles. However,
the Chachamim decided differently.
If the Haftarah "Ha'lo ki'vnei
Kushiyim atem Beis Yisrael " is
accepted, so what is
the central theme?
What is the central theme
of Acharei Mos and Kedoshim?
What?
Galus.
And how to avoid it, the Haftarah should
answer how
to avoid galus,
how not to be trapped by galus.
Not to be confronted
by that curse of galus.
And if, Rachmana litzlan, chas v'shalom,
a Jew should be exiled from his
land, how to get back to the land.
And that is why Chazal chose
the Haftarah from Amos.
He gives the answer, Amos.
Before Isaiah and before
Yirmiyahu and before
Yechezkel, Amos proclaimed
the emunah,
our faith in shivas bnei ha'golah
l'Eretz Yisrael, in the returning of our
people from captivity to Eretz Yisrael.
And they chose the Haftarah of -- the
portion of Amos, from Amos' prophecy,
which is most characteristic for "V'lo
saki ha'aretz es'chem" -- I mean, most
characteristic and the most direct,
which has a direct -- I would say,
A direct approach to the curse of galus
which was mentioned in the parshah.
"V'shavti es shvus ami
Yisrael," and I will return,
I mean,
from captivity my people, Yisrael,
"u'vanu arim neshamos," and they'll
build waste cities or desolate cities,
"v'yashavu," and they'll settle
there, "v'natu keramim v'shasu es
yeinam," and they'll plant vineyards
and they'll drink the wine up.
"U'neta'atim al admasam," I'll plant
them on their land, but this time a
little -- in a different manner than
I planted them before, "v'lo yinat'shu
od mei'al admasam," they will not be
removed from the soil in which I shall
resettle them, "amar Adoshem Elokecha."
Isn't this the answer to "V'lo saki
ha'aretz es'chem…
ka'asher ka'ah es ha'goy
asher lifneichem"?
Isn't Amos the answer?
Is Amos m'ein ha'parshah or not?
Of course, it's m'ein ha'parshah.
[Break in audio]
...galus is.
God will not destroy the people.
He may cast out His people from their land
for a short while, yet He
will bring them back from captivity.
We will have to have a painful absence,
strike roots again in the land, and
we'll never be severed from the land.
Could you tell me what is actually --
what motivated Chazal to choose just one
pasuk in Kedoshim and Emor and then
the Haftarah revolve about this pasuk
instead of, I mean, choose -- selecting
the gufei Torah in Kedoshim and in
Emor and find the appropriate Haftarah
which will fit those gufei Torah?
We all know why it is
so, why they chose it.
Because the people, in the
time of Chazal, when -- I mean,
needed support and encouragement.
And, particularly, they had to
believe that all the persecutions,
that the galus is just a temporary,
transient phenomenon, Hakadosh Baruch Hu
will finally bring them back.
The emunah b'bias ha'Mashiach would
have been undermined if Chazal hadn't
selected the last pasuk in Amos as the
response to the warning of galus, which
Moshe addressed to the people.
Yes, the people might be exiled.
They might lose their land and everything
which they shared, and everything
which was dear and holy to them, but
this is just a transient phenomenon.
They'll come back to the land, and
whatever they lost will be recovered.
And, of course, it
is -- galus is bad, even if it's
transient and short-lived,
just a short experience.
However, the final destiny of the Jew will
be fulfilled, the way Amos
foresaw and Amos predicted.
At this point, we encounter the very
principle which lies at the root of
the Haftarah institution in general.
See, we have two institutions.
We have krias ha'Torah, and we
have the Navi, krias ha'Navi.
What's the difference between
those two institutions?
Krias ha'Torah was simply introduced in
order to acquaint the people with the
Torah, to acquaint them with the laws.
You know, I mean, in the time of Chachmei
ha'Talmud, they had a meturgeman who
used to explain and tell them what
the laws are.
This was first.
Then, the Haftarah was introduced
for a different reason.
As far as the law is concerned,
"Sh'ein ha'Navi rashai lechadesh
davar," a Navi cannot add anything,
I mean, to the system of law
which was given to us by Hakadosh
Baruch Hu through Moshe, through Moses.
The nevu'os, the institution of Haftarah
was introduced for a different purpose.
Namely what?
To strengthen the faith of the people in
the final redemption and the final return
to Eretz Yisrael of the Knesset Yisrael.
One word. the Haftarah
serves -- the Haftarah reminds
the people of bias ha'Mashiach.
And if you want, I mean, you may
ask me how did I arrive at this conclusion?
What do you say?
Because if you read the brachos of
the Haftarah, so you will realize
immediately that all the brachos revolve,
circle around one article of faith.
Remember, "V'davar echad mi'devarecha
achur lo yashuv reikam ki melech ne'eman
v'rachum atah." Whatever You promised will
come true, that the great eschatological,
Messianic promise will finally be realized.
No matter how difficult times were, no
matter how difficult it was to believe
in the final restoration of all its
glory and the fulfillment of all hopes,
nevertheless, in spite of all the
difficulties, the promise of Hakadosh
Baruch Hu to His people will come true.
And here we have the problem.
On the one hand, the people
listened to krias ha'Torah,
and the people got frightened.
They couldn't understand.
The land to which they are
marching -- after all, they were on
their march from Mitzrayim to Eretz
Yisrael -- will be given to them
just for a short while.
If they should commit sins -- and
they knew very well that sins
are going to be committed.
A man is just -- he's unlimited
in his freedom, in his choice.
If they should commit
the sins, they'll be
cast off -- cast out of the land.
They'll be vomited out of the land.
So,
why Mitzrayim?
Why yetzias Mitzrayim?
Why Matan Torah?
They couldn't understand it.
And what could, I mean, the
people -- the contemporaries of
the Chachmei ha'Talmud understand?
So, that's why the prophecy by Amos
was introduced: to tell the people
no matter how bad galus is and no
matter how severe the punishment
will be -- as a matter of fact,
there would be no need to punish.
It's a natural consequence.
Galus is a natural consequence of sin.
Sin and Eretz Yisrael are
somehow mutually exclusive, yes.
No matter how difficult, the
final destiny will be realized.
And this destiny would be the Jew will be planted in Eretz Yisrael,
not for a short time,
not as a transient or just as a temporary
guest or visitor in Eretz Yisrael,
but he'll be planted in a manner
that he'll become a part of the land.
And, "v'lo yinat'shu
od mei'al admasam," they will
never be removed from the land.
In the interest, the whole Haftarah
serves the same -- this purpose, to
assure the Jew of the final realization
of all the promises given to him by God.
And this was the best place where the
Jew was -- should have been reminded
that in spite of the martyrdom we will
have to experience, the final destiny
of ours, which is combined with Eretz
Yisrael, will be fulfilled and realized.
So, what is the m'ein ha'parshah
as far as Acharei Mos and
Kedoshim are concerned?
What's the m'ein ha'parshah?
Where is the parallelism,
the similarity?
Galus and geulah.
Temporary galus
and permanent geulah.
If you take the pasuk in Acharei
Mos-Kedoshim and you compare it with the
few pessukim in Amos, so you arrive at
the m'ein ha'parshah consisted in having
assured the people that the galus will
be short, the geulah will be forever.
And may I add a
personal -- something personal?
It took me months until I unraveled that.
I couldn't understand.
Finally, it dawned upon me.
This is the law.
This is the last part of Amos, "v'lo
yinat'shu od mei'al admasam." That's
what made this parshah, as not to say
-- which converted, actually, the Haftarah,
instead of condemning the people for
abominations, the Navi, I mean,
brings words of solace and
encouragement and faith to the people.
Now, I'm expecting a question.
Yeah, expecting a question.
Is it all right?
Is everything so smooth that
there's not a single question?
What?
[Inaudible]
Because the galus is mentioned twice
in Acharei Mos and Kedoshim, so we read
the same Haftarah on the Shabbos of
Acharei Mos and the Shabbos of Kedoshim.
We don't want that the warning
of galus be read without reacting
or without responding to it.
That's why
the very moment we read about the
possibility of galus, we right away
-- because the "v'lo saki ha'aretz es'chem"
is at the end of the parshiyos, at
the end of Acharei Mos and the end
of Kedoshim -- right away we respond.
Yes, it will happen, but God will
return the people from captivity to
Eretz Yisrael, and that time forever.
They'll stay in Eretz Yisrael forever.
I want you to know I'm not
speaking like a Zionist.
I don't preach Zionism.
This has nothing to do with Zionism.
This is guf ha'shoter.
There is another problem
which you have to solve.
Namely, the Navi did not say
how the Jews will come back.
What will make
them return?
And did not
-- the Navi did not tell us what -- whether
or not the land will wait for us.
Perhaps, the land will not wait for us.
It could be occupied, invaded,
cultivated and developed into a civilized
country without our participation.
It was a historical possibility.
How is a return to the land which
vomited out its inhabitants 1,900 years
ago -- because they defiled themselves
and as well as her -- possible?
How is such a return possible?
Does the land wait so long for
her children to come back the way
a loving mother waits the return
of her child, of her only child,
or the land is not as tender,
not as loving as a mother is?
What guarantees the return
of the children to the land?
There's a question that's
basically a double question.
Does the land wait for her children,
and do the children want to come back?
It's a double question.
It's not one question.
There's no answer in Amos about it.
There's no answer.
In Amos, there is promise,
pledge, havtachah.
Yes, but Amos does not explain to us how.
What is the guarantee?
What will make the bond so permanent
and strong between people and land?
What is responsible for
the patience
which the Knesses Yisrael, on the one
hand, and the land, Eretz Yisrael, on
the other hand, will wait or will expect
the return of the children to the land?
I believe that answer -- this answer
lies in a halachic category.
This is my opinion.
I have thought about it a lot.
I believe this
is to be found -- the answer is to
be found in a halachic category.
Namely, what would you suggest?
Which category in a halachic term,
Namely, what?
What guarantees?
Where is the -- document, the shtar?
I said halachic term.
I mean, it's a very simple word.
I mean, I haven't discovered anything new.
Namely, that somehow our
rights to Eretz Yisrael.
We have rights, that's
at least what people say.
We have a right to the land.
We are the rightful owners of the land.
As well as our rights to the
Beis Hamikdash, to the Har
Habayis or to Yerushalayim.
And by the way, again, it's not Zionism.
This is Torah Sh'be'al Peh.
Let me say, according to the
halachah, Yerushalayim is not a city.
It's called Ir David, yes, but
al pi halachah, it is not a city.
Yerushalayim is a part of the Beis Hamikdash.
It’s one kedusha.
Shalosh machanos hen Yisrael.
In the midbar, the people were divided
into three camps: Machaneh Yisrael, the
camp of the Israelites, of the ordinary
Jews; Machaneh Levi, Leviyah, of the camp
of the Levites; and finally, Machaneh
Shechinah, the camp where God resides.
Yerushalayim is Machaneh Yisrael;
it's a part of the Beis Hamikdash.
Our claims to Yerushalayim are not
only based on the promise which
the Almighty gave to Abraham
with regard to Eretz Yisrael.
Not only on that promise, but it's also,
I mean, based upon the parshah, Re'eih,
"l'shichno tidreshu u'vasa shamah," you
will detect the place where He resides,
and to that place you will be coming.
Yerushalayim is actually two
-- there are two kedushos to Yerushalayim.
Kedushas ha'aretz, the kedushah
which pervades the entire land, its
entire topography and geography.
And secondly, kedushas ha'mikdash,
the kedushah which pervades the Har
Habayis as well as Yerushalayim.
Different types.
With Eretz Yisrael, our right to Eretz
Yisrael as a land or to Yerushalayim
not only as a city but as a part
of the Beis Hamikdash, our right to
both the land as well as Yerushalayim
is based upon one word: kedushah.
Without kedushah, we have no right.
If someone should deny kedushas ha'aretz
or should deny kedushas Yerushalayim,
to say the land is a land like
any other territory, and Yerushalayim
is just a city and the Har Habayis
is just a just a hill or -- nowadays,
it is a valley, you go downstairs
in order to get to Har Habayis,
that there is nothing unique,
there is nothing singular about the
land and Yerushalayim.
So, by making that statement, he
forfeits all rights to Yerushalayim
and to the Beis Hamikdash.
It's a question of kedushah.
Now, there is a plain problem with
which the Baalei Tosfos preoccupy
themselves, as well as many Rishonim.
But the most outstanding Rishon who
actually introduced a new concept, a new
perspective with regard to that problem
of kedushah, is Maimonides, the Rambam.
Excuse me, I'm assimilated.
You can't resist the galus.
There is a question, let me ask.
I'm trying to develop Maimonides'
idea, but I'll change the
vocabulary a little bit.
There is a question which
should be formulated properly
and answered courageously.
Are churban and kedushah, two good
words -- I mean, two words in the
Hebrew language -- churban u'kedushah,
two mutually exclusive categories?
Two opposites?
They contradict each other.
Desolation
and the presence of kedushah are
mutually exclusive, are two opposites,
because kedushah resides in binyan, in
beautiful architecture, in orderliness,
in wholesomeness and in prosperity.
Desolation, debris, ruins, ashes
permeate all kinds of kedushah and
the exalted disappears under
the ruins and the debris.
Ashes covers up kedushah,
and the kedushah vanishes.
This is one approach,
I mean, halachically.
Or, the reverse is true.
Or the reverse is true, is correct.
Kedushah tolerates churban.
And Hakadosh Baruch Hu can reside not
only in a beautiful Beis Hamikdash but on
the desolate mount of "Har Tzion
sh'shameim shu'alim hilchu bo." He
can reside on the desolate mount
where the foxes come up and
down -- walk up and down.
He can be covered with ashes and
debris and still reside in that
particular spot, which is frightening
as far as desolation is concerned.
It's a problem, a halachic problem.
Strange, this problem was picked up
in the Torah
in Bechukosai.
In the parshah which
we just read last Shabbos.
There is a strange pasuk in Bechukosai.
"V'nasasi es
areichem chor ," and I'll
make your towns desolate, "va'hashimosi
es mikdasheichem," and I'll
make your sanctuaries or your
batei mikdash desolate,
"v'lo ari'ach b'rei'ach nichochachem.
Va'hashimosi ani es ha'aretz v'shamemu
aleha oyveichem ha'yoshvim bah."
And I will make your cities a waste,
and will bring your
sanctuaries into desolation.
And I will bring the land into
desolation, and your enemies
that will dwell thereof will be astonished.
But let us just select three words:
"va'hashimosi es mikdasheichem," and I'll
make your sanctuaries waste or desolate.
We just read it.
This phrase, "va'hashimosi es
mikdasheichem," lends itself
to a double interpretation.
Interpretation number one,
your sanctuaries will be in a
state of desolation,
which -- and in consequence,
the kedushah
will be terminated,
since waste and holiness,
desolation and exaltedness,
are mutually exclusive.
"Va'hashimosi es mikdasheichem," I'll
destroy physically your sanctuaries,
completely destroyed, just debris, ashes,
dumping places,
and by destroying the physical
sanctuaries, I'll destroy the idea
of kedushah which hovered over them.
There'll be no mikdasheichem anymore
because shimamon u'mikdash, as I
said before, are mutually exclusive.
"I shall make your mikdashim a waste."
Of course, this
is the negative interpretation.
This can be interpreted
in the positive as well.
"Va'hashimosi es mikdasheichem,"
how I'll destroy physically
your batei mikdash,
even though, nevertheless, they'll remain
mikdasheichem, in spite of everything.
So, actually, there are two
p'shatim, two interpretations.
What's your opinion, the
right interpretation?
I don't mean the interpretation you like.
I mean, from the standpoint of Torah
Sh'be'al Peh, which one is right?
Huh?
Yeah, I
know that I have your endorsement.
You agree with it.
Yeah, I couldn't decide
between such -- between
the two interpretations
without quoting a Gemara.
The Gemara helps out sometimes.
The Gemara helps.
They are very helpful.
The Mishnah
in Megillah, I believe it's one
of the last Mishnayos in Megillah.
"Beis ha'knesses sh'charav,"
a beis ha'knesses which
was destroyed, was consumed by fire
or desecrated by our enemies, just
debris, a heap of debris and ruins.
So, all the laws pertaining to beis
ha'knesses applies not only to a
beis ha'knesset which is built but
to a beis ha'knesset which is in
desolation, in a state of waste.
"Sh'ne'emar," the Mishnah says,
"'Va'hashimosi es mikdasheichem'
af al pi sh'shomemin hemah," even
though they are they are desolate,
"bi'kedushasan hen omdin," the kedushah
has not disappeared, has not vanished.
Kedushah is not frightened by churban.
The Rambam, in Hilchos Beis
Ha'Bechirah, developed the idea
that kedushas ha'mikdash, which was
introduced by King Solomon, by Shlomo
Hamelech, continued throughout the
ages and the millennia to hover over
b'Yerushalayim in the Har Habayis
and "kedushah rishona kidshah l'sha'atah v'kidshah l'asid lavo."
The first kedushah, meaning Shlomo's --
King Solomon's kedushah or
David's kedushah --
we don't know exactly who consecrated the Beis Hamikdash, Shlomo or David.
We don't know, but it
doesn't matter as far as
we are concerned.
Throughout the millennia, since the
first kiddush, the kedushah prevailed,
regardless of the fact that
so many years, the Beis Hamikdash has
been in a state of desolation.
Physical desolation does not
cancel the category -- does not
eliminate kedushah and exaltedness.
The exaltedness of the place, why?
The Rambam asks himself, why?
Why do I say so?
Why does it --
as a matter of fact, with regard
to kedushas ha'aretz, to the holiness
of the land, to the sanctity of the
land, the Rambam is of the opinion that
the kedushah which was introduced by
Yehoshua was discontinued at the time of
Nevuchadnetzar when his legions occupied
Eretz Yisrael, invaded Eretz Yisrael.
So why kedushat Shlomo was not
discontinued -- was continued throughout
the ages, and kedushas Yehoshua was
discontinued throughout the ages?
It was discontinued?
So, the Rambam answers -- I
mean, you all know the answer.
Kedushas ha'aretz in
the time of Yehoshua was
based upon power, upon military
victory, upon conquest.
Yehoshua was strong, he conquered
the land, he consecrated the
land and hallowed the land.
Nevuchadnetzar was stronger, he
conquered the land, he put an
end to the kedushas ha'aretz.
But the Beis Hamikdash, he says,
"eino ela mipnei haShechinah."
The fact that the Beis Hamikdash
is kovesh is not because somebody
conquered the Beis Hamikdash, because
of military conquest, but because the
Shechinah resides, abides
on that particular spot.
"U'Shechinah einah beteilah
l'olam," the Shechinah is never
-- can never be removed from that particular
spot, "v'harei hu omer 'Va'hashimosi es
mikdasheichem' v'amru Chachamim af al
pi sh'shomemin hen bi'kedushasan havei."
True, God abides in both, in
binyan as well as in churban.
Kedushah and churban are
not conflicting ideas.
God abides in splendor and in grandeur, in
the vast stretches of the universe -- of
course, "Ha'shamayim kis'i v'ha'aretz
hadom raglai" -- as well as in the
desolation, loneliness, bleakness on
the Har Habayis throughout the ages.
As a beautiful universe with
endless, uncharted lanes, and all
that is just the abode of God.
Why should He reside on a lonely
mountain or hill, which -- I mean, and be
covered with ashes and debris?
Why should God not move away from
that particular spot?
Apparently, God has a different approach.
He resides in the universe, "m'lo
kol ha'aretz kevodo." He resides
in a small place which is bleak and
dreary, and which for 1,900 years has
stood alone, lonely, without hope.
God refused to leave this spot
on which His house once stood.
The sanctity of that spot
continued throughout the ages.
So, the Mishnah and the Rambam --
I mean, he quoted the Mishnah --
have decided
that "Va'hashimosi es
mikdasheichem" should be interpreted
in the Torah into the positive.
It means, "af al pi sh'shomemin,"
even though they are desolate, there
is desolation, still, "bi'kedushasan
omdin," their kedushah continues.
Now let me ask you.
Why did the Chachamim
interpret it like that?
Yes?
Why?
What prompted them to
interpret it like that?
"Va'hashimosi es mikdasheichem" means
I'll simply destroy your sanctuaries and
the idea of kedushah and the exaltedness
will vanish.
The land, Yerushalayim and the Har
Habayis will be just as holy as any
other spot, or just as profane
as any other spot in the world,
in the universe.
[Inaudible]
Yeah, but the question is correct, I know.
But, however, if the Mishnah in
Megillah said so and the Rambam
accepted it -- and the Rambam also
quoted the Mishnah in Megillah,
apparently there is a reason, and that
reason has got to be found in Chumash
-- not in Chumash exactly.
I mean, in Torah Sh'biksav,
which prompted our scholars, our
rabbis to interpret "Va'hashimosi
es mikdasheichem" in a positive
sense, not in a negative sense.
What forced them?
[Inaudible]
Yes, yes, but
what about the Chumash?
Avraham Avinu.
[Inaudible]
It might be.
I believe
Huh?
[Inaudible]
What?
I don't know.
If Amos knows the answer,
I would have asked him.
No, there's got to be -- this answer
has got to be developed in basic terms,
in our outlook upon the world, in our
perspective, in our world perspective.
I believe -- I mean, did you -- last
Shabbos, when you heard the Maftir
of Bechukosai, did you ask yourself
what is the link between the Maftir of
Bechukosai and the parshah of Bechukosai?
The same question which I
raised with regard to Amos,
[inaudible]
Acharei Mos-Kedoshim,
I raised the question, what has got
Amos -- what has got the Haftarah
of "Adoshem uzi u'ma'uzi" -- this
was the Haftarah last Shabbos -- got
to do with the parshah where the
tochachah is made -- was formulated?
What?
If you ask me, three words in the
parshah, six words in Yirmiyahu.
If you have a Chumash Vayikra, open up
the Book of Vayikra, and choose -- and
cast a glance on the Haftarah.
There are six words, strange words,
but those six words have influenced
our Chazal, our rabbis, to interpret
"'Va'hashimosi es mikdashechem' af
al pi sh'shomemin hen bi'kedushasan
omdin" enthusiastically in terms
of our emunah in the future of
Eretz Yisrael and Yerushalayim.
What?
Six words.
And that's why this Haftarah was chosen,
this portion of the Prophet was chosen
-- Yirmiyahu was chosen to be the Haftarah
of Bechukosai, Behar and Bechukosai.
"V'shamatetah u'vecha mi'nachalasecha"?
What what what?
Now you are guessing.
Correct.
There is a strange pasuk.
Correct, correct, it was said already.
Oh, I'll let you finish.
Yes, here we read a very strange sentence.
"Kisei kavod marom mei'rishon mekom
mikdasheinu. Mikveh Yisrael atah."
The throne of glory on high --
and it happens that the traditional
translation is pretty good here.
The throne of glory, on high from the
beginning, the place of our sanctuary.
The hope of Israel, O Lord.
What does it mean?
"Kisei kavod marom mei'rishon," the
kisei kavod which was established
from the very beginning, "mekom
mikdasheinu," the abode of our sanctuary.
"Mikveh Yisrael," you
are the hope of Israel.
What idea did the Navi express or
formulate in this short six-word sentence
which has played such great importance,
I mean, for the interpretation of
"Va'hashimosi es mikdashechem." What idea?
I mean, you have
you all know the idea.
I call this idea the double image theory.
The double image theory,
don’t get frightened, it’s not philosophy.
Double image theory.
The word double image theory, I
derived the term -- it's my term.
I haven't plagiarized anyone.
The double image theory, I derived
this term from a story in Chumash
which we all know, from the story
in Chumash about Jacob who stopped
over for the night in a certain
place, when he saw the ladder, you
know, I mean, standing on the ground
and reaching the skies, heavens.
"U'malachei
Elokim olim v'yordim bo," and the
angels of God were climbing up
and descending along this ladder.
So you are so the
Gemara in Chullin says,
"Olim lema'alah yordim
lematah," they go down to Jacob,
real Jacob, the physical Jacob, who
was sparkling with d'mus deyukno.
And they take a good look at his
face, at his countenance, his body.
Is he good-looking, or isn't he?
"V'olim lema'alah u'mistaklin
b'd'mus deyukno,"
and they go up to heaven
and they take
another look, but this time not at the
physical Jacob -- the physical Jacob
was sleeping -- at the Jacob whose
image was engraved in the Kisei Hakavod.
That's what Rashi says in Chullin.
So, in other words, each Jew has
two images, the image from lematah,
the physical image, and the image
of lema'alah, the image which is
engraved in the Kisei Hakavod.
And not only people have a double image.
Any institution in Yahadus
has a double image.
Shabbos.
It's a day of rest.
So, the Midrash tells us -- excuse me,
Rabbi Lamm came and mentioned the Zohar,
so I have to mention it, too, now.
The Zohar, I
believe, in the hakdamah of Vayakhel -- I
don't remember exactly -- it says,
"V'shabbsosai tishmoru." So, "Ha'hu
Taya," the Bedouin who met Rabbi
Shimon bar Yochai -- the Bedouin,
the famous Bedouin, Taya, who was
acquainted with kol ha'Torah kulah.
This Bedouin met Rabbi Shimon bar
Yochai and asked him why is the Shabbos
mentioned in the plural, not in the
singular, "Shabbsosai tishmoru." So,
Rabbi Shimon bar Yochai didn't know.
So, the Bedouin began to
deliver a shiur about it.
And finally, the consequence of
that treatise which the Bedouins
developed the idea that Shabbos
has two images, too.
One image, Shabbos mi'l'tatah and Shabbos
l'ilaah, two images, two different images.
Whoever, and I believe there are many
Chassidim here, even though lately they
stopped saying K'gavna, in fact, but
there are some here who say K'gavna.
The whole idea of the double
image of Shabbos is actually,
I mean, expressed in K'gavna.
Next time, Friday night, you'll pay
attention to what you are saying.
[Break in audio]
And basically, it's not Isaiah.
It's more than Isaiah.
It's a Mishnah in Ta’anit, that
the Levi'im used to say shirah.
Every day, they had a separate -- a
different psalm, a different shirah.
On Shabbos, "Hayu omrim 'Mizmor
shir l'yom ha'Shabbos'… lavo l'yom
sh'kulo Shabbos menuchah l'chayei
ha'olamim." And I heard once from
my father, zichron livrachah, in
the name of Reb Chaim that the
Nevi'im used to say so actually.
They used to say on Shabbos, "Mizmor
shir l'yom ha'Shabbos," the beginning
of the psalm and then they used
to conclude, "Mizmor shir l'yom
ha'Shabbos l'yom sh'kulo Shabbos
u'menuchah l'chayei ha'olamim."
Again, there are two
Shabbatot, two Shabbosim.
We have the Shabbos l'satah.
We say day and the week.
On the week, a Jew has to abstain
from work and have a different -- and
adopt a different lifestyle, but it
is just -- it's an ordinary Shabbos.
It's a day on which you don't work.
That's all.
And the day on which you study
Torah, correct, because the Shabbos
is consecrated in study on Shabbat.
but that’s all.
Well, there's a Shabbos
l'eilah, a Shabbos above.
Shabbos l'eilah
is l'yom sh'kulo Shabbos, a day
which is -- whose entirety and
very essence is Shabbos, sh'kulo
Shabbos and expresses itself in
a variety of ways, in particular,
in menuchah l'chayei ha'olamim.
So, basically, it's a Mishnah, even
though I may call your attention.
Rashi in Rosh Hashanah differs with
Reb Chaim in the p'shat, "L'yom sh'kulo
Shabbos umenuchah l'chayei ha'olamim."
So, if you look up the Rashi in
Rosh Hashanah, they ruled, beis din,
so you'll find that I was wrong.
But anyway, in Shabbos, we
have the two ideas of Shabbos
l'satah, of Shabbos l'eilah.
We know very well that as far as Beis
Hamikdash and Yerushalayim are concerned,
there is certainly a double image theory.
Who doesn't know of Yerushalayim shel
matah and Yerushalayim shel ma'alah?
Even Zionists know about it.
Who doesn't know of Beis Hamikdash shel
ma'alah and Beis Hamikdash shel matah?
It's mentioned in Az Yashir.
"Mikdash Adoshem konenu
yadecha. Adoshem yimloch l'olam va'ed."
Where is
all that mentioned in
Yirmiyahu, in our Haftarah?
Kisei kavod.
The Kisei Hakavod, the throne of glory.
Marom mei'rishon, on the very
beginning, even before the beginning.
Is mekom mikdasheinu, when a Jew speaks
about the Beis Hamikdash, he has in mind
not the brick and the mortar and the
sand and the gold in the Beis Hamikdash.
This is not the Beis Hamikdash,
ha'Beis Hamikdash shel lematah.
But there is another Beis Hamikdash.
"Kisei kavod marom mei'rishon" which is "mekom mikdasheinu."
There is a Beis Hamikdash
shel ma'alah
and that is why mikveh Yisrael.
We have hope in the Almighty.
That is the reason why "Va'hashimosi
ani es mikdasheichem" was interpreted in
positive terms, not in negative terms.
Why is it "af al pi sh'shomemin
bi'kedushasan omdin"?
Yeah, the enemy could have destroyed and did destroy everything,
but not the Beis Hamikdash shel ma'alah, d'marom mei'rishon mekom mikdasheinu.
And as long as the mekom
mikdasheinu exists,
so the Shechinah resides not only lema'alah but lematah as well.
And if the Shechinah resides,
is mikveh Yisrael.
So we have hope that everything
will be restored.
And the people will return, and that
neither the land will forget her children,
nor will the children forget their mother.
This pasuk, "Kisei kavod marom mei'rishon
mekom mikdasheinu. Mikveh Yisrael."
And it's very strange, that the tochachah,
where it speaks of "Va'hashimosi es
mikdasheichem" is accompanied by the
nevu'ah of Yirmiyahu, who was the
prophet of churban, of desolation, but
still, he told the people, don't worry.
There will be churban,
there will be desolation.
Many things will be destroyed,
but not the mekom mikdasheinu.
And as long as the mekom mikdasheinu
is marom mei'rishon, the mikveh
Yisrael will not disappoint you.
And that's why the
Haftarah of Bechukosai was chosen.
This chapter in Jeremiah was chosen
as the Haftarah of Bechukosai.
Because without the chapter of
Jeremiah, without this six-word
sentence, I would have said that
"Va'hashimosi es mikdasheichem"
should be interpreted in the negative.
I'll destroy not only the physical
structure but the kedushah as well.
What saved the "Va'hashimosi es
mikdasheichem" is this six-word
sentence: "Kisei kavod marom
mei'rishon mekom mikdasheinu."
So, it's very strange now.
Acharei Mos and Kedoshim
started with what?
With the problem of galus.
Amos, we already recited Amos, who
tells the people -- what does he
actually -- the synopsis of Amos' message?
Don't be frightened.
You'll lose -- you might lose Eretz
Yisrael for a while, a short while or
sometimes for a long time, but the final
destiny of the people of Israel, of the
Knesset Yisrael, will be fully realized.
You will come back and then
the land will be yours forever.
And we asked, we are not
satisfied with Amos' answer.
We ask, I mean, where is the guarantee?
Who is the orev, so to say?
Who endorses the promise?
So, when we come
from Acharei Mos-Kedoshim to
Behar and Bechukosai,
where is the endorsement in that?
In Behar, the story about Yirmiyahu,
who bought real estate, purchased the
field from his uncle on the day on which
Yerushalayim,
was attacked by Nevuchadnetzar.
And God gave him to --
I mean, and he gave his
uncle -- his uncle gave him two documents,
two deeds, the chasum and the galuy,
the mysterious deed and the plain deed.
And the Navi said, "od yikanu batim
v'sados u'keramim b'harei Yerushalayim."
And particularly, what was important
is the sentence, "Kisei kavod
marom mei'rishon
mekom mikdasheinu.
Mikveh Yisrael Adoshem." This
is actually the guarantees in the
double image theory of the mikdash
lematah and mikdash lema'alah.
That's it.
So, is Acharei Mos and Kedoshim -- I
mean, state the fact that Yisrael
will come back to Eretz Yisrael from
captivity, explains, I mean, the reasons
why we believe so, so strongly believe
in the return of the children to Eretz
Yisrael is because of this six-word
sentence, "Kisei kavod marom mei'rishon
mekom mikdasheinu. Mikveh Yisrael."
That means
the one unit, Acharei Mos and Kedoshim
and Behar and Bechukosai is one unit.
There is fright of galus,
there is consolation,
and then Jeremiah explains
to us what is the reason.
I mean, what guarantee do we
have that the Beis Hamikdash in
Eretz Yisrael will be restored?
And the guarantee is mekom
mikdasheinu, "Kisei kavod marom
mei'rishon mekom mikdasheinu."
Now,
next.
There is
another haftarah in Parshas Vayikra.
I mean in the Sefer Vayikra.
And which is accompanied
as usual by a haftarah.
And the question as far as this
haftarah is concerned is not so
much about the common denominator.
As a matter of fact, not only do
they have a common motif,
they are almost identical.
The parsha and haftarah
are almost identical.
And I would like to
gain a few insights into the
haftarah because there is a problem.
So, what is new about it?
I mean, the navi repeats exactly what
the Torah said.
Which haftarah you have in mind?
Which one?
I don't hear.
Emor, correct.
Emor, if you open up your Chumash
and you study the haftarah of Emor,
it's a repetition, almost verbatim
repetition of the Torah shebichtav.
And so the question now is reversed.
Why was it chosen?
Another haftarah should have been chosen.
But here is simply repetition.
Of course, this problem
is not doesn't bother me.
But I believe that I would
like to explain to you the haftarah of
Emor, what did this haftarah do with
regard to our final hope of geulas Yisrael.
The haftarah of Parshas Emor
is almost repetition of
the text of the Torah.
However, a thorough analysis will
yield interesting conclusions.
First,
let me ask you a simple question.
The book of Vayikra, particularly
the Parshas Emor, deals almost
exclusively with the laws
pertaining to kohanim, kehuna.
It is called Toras Kohanim.
So Yechezkel
in his prophecies, quite a number of
prophecies, repeats the laws of kehuna.
I mean, those laws with regard to which
the kohen has a different is commanded.
Those laws which the kohen is commanded to
fulfill in contrast with a Yisrael who is
not duty bound to comply with those laws.
I don't have to tell
you what I have in mind.
Now,
but if you start reading the
haftarah of Yechezkel, will
somebody read the pasuk in Yechezkel?
Yes, just read a pasuk from Yechezkel.
Alright, it is [inaudible].
Vehakohanim haLeviim bnei Tzadok
asher shamru mishmeres mikdashi bisos
bnei Yisrael me'alai, heimah yikrevu
elai lesharteni, heimah yavo'u el
mikdashi, veheimah yakrivu al shulchani
lesharteni, veshamru es mishmeres.
When you hear the pasuk, and if
you open a Chumash and
read it carefully, there is one
difference between Emor and, and I'm
not speaking about the differences which
Chazal already, I mean, dealt with,
vealmanah asher tihyeh
almana lekohein yikachu,
This is Chazal already,
I mean, they dealt with
this problem.
But I, I'm dealing with something else.
The book of Vayikra the sedra of
Emor is a code of laws, is a code
where the laws pertaining, the special
laws pertaining to the kohen were
formulated by the Torah, correct?
In particular the laws which are
related to the kohen personally not
him as far as the kohen is meaning as
far as the ministrations of
the kohen unto the Almighty.
But as far as the person of the kohen
is concerned, ve'isha zona vachalala
lo yikachu, ve'isha gerusha me'isha
lo yikachu and so forth, al kol
nafshos meis lo yavo,
all right.
This is in Emor.
The pasuk in the haftarah
starts with what?
Vehakohanim haLeviim bnei Tzadok asher
shamru mishmeres mikdashi bisos bnei
Yisrael me'alai, heimah yikrevu elai
lesharteni, heimah yavo'u el mikdashi.
And whoever studies Yechezkel carefully,
in the previous chapters, Yechezkel
tells us the following story: that
many kohanim have betrayed the kehuna.
And they walked away from the kehuna.
Many became defiled with avodah zarah.
Many because they intermarried or they
married women who were not qualified
to marry a kohen, and so forth.
But there was a Bnei Tzadok, a family
of kohanim called Bnei Tzadok, who were
committed, totally committed to the law,
to the Torah, and to Hakadosh Baruch Hu.
And when all people, all the people,
bisos Bnei Yisrael went astray,
bitos Bnei Yisrael, they remained
steadfast in their commitment, and
they continued to live like kohanim
the way the Torah has required of them.
Bisos Bnei Yisrael hakohanim
haLeviim bnei Tzadok asher shamru
mishmeres mikdashi, which I mean not so
much guarding the Beis Hamikdash, there
was no Beis Hamikdash to be guarded,
for 70 years of churban, there wasn't.
Asher shamru es mikdashi means they
they lived in accordance with the law.
Bitos Bnei Yisrael me'alai, at
a time when the the people of
Israel, many, the majority, separated
themselves from Me and they went astray.
What Yechezkel is saying
is something very important.
Emor contains the laws of kehuna,
the law of kehuna, the law.
Yechezkel in the haftarah,
in the haftarah to Emor,
is speaking about kehuna
as a promise, that kehuna
will not disappear.
That kehuna will exist, will continue
forever.
Because I want you to know, a kohen
is not, kehuna is not just a matter of
nesias kapayim or of being called up.
When we speak about kehuna, we don't
have in mind only nesias kapayim.
Nesias kapayim is a mitzvah, correct.
But there is something
more than nesias kapayim.
There is something more
than being called up,
I mean, to the sefer Torah.
Kehuna is a part of kedushas Yisrael.
Am Yisrael, the
people of Israel, I mean,
the nation, is ama
tlisai, the Gemara says.
Is a three-structured
or threefold community.
Ama tlisai, a threefold nation.
It is Kohen, Levi, Yisrael.
And this is a part of the kedusha, of kedushas Yisrael.
That within kedushas Yisrael, we have three degrees of kedusha.
Kedushas kehuna, kedushas
Levi, and kedushas Yisrael.
And,
if there is an institution
which is exposed to
defilement and to disintegration,
this is the institution of kehuna.
Already when Ezra came back from from
Bavel, so you read in Ezra and Nechemiah
about Ezra's struggles, efforts,
to restore the old kehuna, because
the people in Bavel intermarried,
intermarried into Gentile families.
They intermarried as
far as pesulei kehuna are concerned.
There were the children, and of course,
intermarriage whether the secular Jews
like it or dislike it, a intermarriage
affects the status of the child.
Some children are goyim goyim.
Some children are mamzerim.
Some children are chalalim.
I mean, you can't help it, you
can't help it, this is the law.
But of course, I mean, after they
had been exiled from Eretz Yisrael
and they had they lost control over
marriages and kehuna u'leviya and
ordinary kedushas Yisrael in Bavel,
so they actually, I mean, lost
control over kedushas Yisrael.
And many kohanim were put
aside and they were told they
cannot minister unto the Almighty
in the Beis Hamikdash, nor were
they permitted to eat terumah.
And you read in Ezra Nechemiah,
ad amod kohen leUrim velaTumim.
Those people cannot be identified
as kohanim, they'll have to wait
for the Melech Hamashiach to
give them the identity of kehuna.
And kehuna is a very fragile
institution, very fragile.
Particularly, I discovered it, I
discovered it in the United States.
When I became a Rav in the United
States, and in Boston, the first
wedding I performed, so the
chosson was all dressed up with a
beautiful carnation on his lapel.
A nice boy,
made an impression of a nice boy.
So then I began to fill in the
kesubah, I said, you have to identify
yourself, Kohen, Levi, or Yisrael.
So I met with a quizzical
look, with astonishment.
He didn't understand
what I was talking about.
So I was astonished.
But I recovered from my astonishment.
You know why?
Because the majority of the Jews
in America, majority, the vast majority,
doesn't know what what kehuna is.
Absolutely does not know what kehuna is.
Meet a Jew on the street,
or a student on a campus.
I don't mean those baalei teshuvah.
I'm not speaking about baalei teshuvah.
I'm speaking about the average
Jew in the United States.
I mean the youth on the campus.
Ask them whether they are Kohen, Levi,
Yisrael, and they wouldn't understand you.
Not only they wouldn't have an
answer, they wouldn't understand
what you are talking to him.
And that's why I always tell the
people, ketanim ugedolim, whether
they reached maturity or they didn't
reach maturity, to go up to duchan.
All children go up to duchan.
It's no time now to play around with
Rashi versus Tosfos whether there is
chinuch on kehuna on birkas kapayim.
Because the whole institution
of kehuna is actually about
to disintegrate and collapse.
There is a terrible problem.
So, in Emor, in Emor, there is no promise
by God that kehuna will exist forever.
The laws of kehuna were formulated.
But Hakadosh Baruch Hu, Moshe, did not
disclose to the people whether kehuna
is going to exist, to continue, or the
people or the Jews will defile the kehuna
the way they have defiled many things.
There is a law of kehuna.
Emor is a parsha which
deals with the laws of kehuna.
It's not a parsha of the
promise that kehuna will exist.
This was Yechezkel's job.
Yechezkel said, before I discuss
the laws of kehuna, what a kohen
is supposed to do, what he's not
supposed to do, let me say one thing.
Let me say one thing.
Kehuna will exist forever.
I understand the menace to kehuna.
I understand the difficulties
which we will meet.
I understand, I understand that it
will be very hard and tough on our
part to preserve the purity of
kehuna, but it will be preserved.
Before Yechezkel
began to tell the people the laws
of kehuna, he says: Vehakohanim
haLeviim bnei Tzadok, a small group
of kohanim the Bnei Kohanim are,
their ancestor was Bnei Tzadok.
But this group distinguished
itself mainly by what?
By its steadfast loyalty and complete
total dedication to the laws of kehuna.
That they served God at a time at
which the people, the majority of
the people lost completely, lost the
understanding for kedushas kehuna.
bitos Bnei Yisrael me'alai, heimah yikrevu
elai lesharteni, veheimah yavo'u el
mikdashi, veheimah yakrivu al shulchani,
veshamru es mishmeres avoseihem.
And believe me that we need
such a promise nowadays as well.
But I believe that Yechezkel's
promise is good for
our times too.
Because chas veshalom if kehuna
should be forgotten, then one
important aspect of kedushas Yisrael
will drop out,
will disappear, will vanish.
Now,
there's another aspect.
There is another aspect which
Yechezkel has developed with regard to
kehuna, which the Torah mentions it,
but not in Emor, but in V'zos Habracha.
But apparently Chazal when
they introduced the haftarah of
Yechezkel, wanted the people to know
immediately what is required of them.
I'll ask a simple question.
Aspect number two.
Number one, Yechezkel introduced
the promise, not only law of kehuna,
but the promise of kehuna, that
kehuna is a permanent institution.
Next, what did Yechezkel
introduce that we found it
important that the prophecy of Yechezkel
became the the haftarah of Emor?
He actually redefined the task of kehuna.
He redefined it.
He reformulated it.
Now let me ask you, what is the sense,
what is the source of kedushas kehuna?
Why are the kohanim superior
as far as kedusha is concerned
to the Leviim and Yisraelim?
What is the source of kedushas kehuna?
To what task is the kohen, should
a kohen be totally committed?
And what actually aspect he
should unreservedly dedicate,
to dedicate himself?
What would you answer?
What is the source of kedushas kehuna?
In what respect does the he possess superiority over the ordinary Jew?
Of course,
the answer is his ministering, his participating in the avodah,
in the service of God,
or ministering unto God.
Is the origin of his specific image
his superior status in the community.
And the pasuk says in Emor, ki
lechem Elokav hu makri vehaya kodesh.
Because the bread of God they do offer,
and therefore they shall be holy.
The holiness of the kohen is a
result of his steady engagement in
worship, in the cultic service of God.
It is the dedication to avodah and
korbanos that generates the kedusha.
I have one question which should be answered.
Kohanim,
you take all the kohanim, I don't know
how many, I mean you have in Shmuel,
I know in Shmuel, Divrei HaYamim,
you have have numbers as far as
the kohanim are concerned, a
report about about the statistics.
But
we know, we know that the kohanim were
divided into how many ... mishmaros?
24, 24 mishmaros, divisions.
See, if you have divided the kehuna in
24 mishmaros, it means that each kohen
could do avodah only two weeks a year.
Two weeks a year.
Because once in every 24 weeks.
All right?
There are few months ...but anyway
it is about two weeks every year.
Moreover, the mishmar was divided
into subdivisions, botei av.
Each beit av served two days a year.
In other words, a kohen used
to serve only two days a year.
That's all.
So let now let me ask, what did
the kohen do the rest of the year?
What did he do the rest of the year?
So you will say nothing?
So the answer is, so why do I
have to give him matnos kehuna?
The whole idea, the whole system of
matnos kehuna is based upon the fact
that the kohanim were preoccupied
with the service in the Beis
Hamikdash, and therefore could not
earn a living by their own efforts.
But I mean,
but it's not
in accordance with the
statistics we just mentioned.
The question was asked by whom?
This question.
It's not a new one.
Who asked this question?
I mean somebody did ask this question.
It's too obvious.
Moshe Rabbeinu.
Where did he ask this question?
In V'zos Habracha.
In his last testament, he addressed
to the people on the day of his
death, of his departure from us.
So he redefined kehuna,
the task of kohanim.
He says, U'leLevi amar, yoru mishpatecha
leYaakov vesorascha leYisrael.
The task of the kohen is
to teach.
Not to minister.
Minister is a secondary task.
Teaching is the main job in which
in which a kohen must be engaged.
Teaching.
Yoru mishpatecha leYaakov, they
should instruct your laws, instruct the
Yaakov in your laws, veSorascha leYisrael.
In addition to that, they have
another cultic job, namely,
to minister unto the Lord.
Yasimu k'torah be'apecha
vechalil al mizbechecha.
But this is the second task.
The first task is yoru mishpatecha
leYaakov veSorascha leYisrael.
The kedusha of kehuna consists
in teaching the people.
Not in ministering, not
exclusively ministering to the
Lord, to God, but in teaching the people.
And the kedushas kehuna consists in a
kedusha of mesorah, of Torah Sheba'al Peh.
They taught the people.
They were the rashei yeshivos,
they were melamdim, they were the
instructors, they were the teachers.
As a matter of fact, a kohen who does
not teach, who does not teach the
people, his kedusha is incomplete.
A Yisrael who teaches the people, he
is engaged in the proper propagation
of God's word, he is engaged in that.
This Yisrael has the status of a kohen.
There is some kedusha.
And perhaps the main source of
kedusha, kedushas kehuna, which
is actually
of an educational character,
namely, the act of teaching.
Did Yechezkel say it?
Ve'es ami yoru, u'vein
tamei letahor yodium.
That's exactly.
Yechezkel ... that the main source of
of kedusha for kohanim is teaching.
And as I emphasized before,
it means in other words, a kohen who
doesn’t teach, actually, I mean, is that
not loses but his kedusha is not exalted
the way it should have been and a Yisrael
who teaches shares in kedushas kehunah.
This is the reason
for inserting Parshas
Moadot in Parshas Emor.
Which is very difficult to understand.
You start Parshas Emor.
What do you have in Parshas Emor?
First of all, tum'as meis.
A kohen cannot defile
himself with a dead body.
Number two, pesul
nashim; whom a kohen is allowed to
marry, whom he is not allowed to marry.
Next, that baalei mumin should
not be offered on the mizbeach.
Again
the law is addressed to the kohanim
because the kohanim used to decide
what is fit
to be an offer and what
is unfit to be an offer.
Suddenly, suddenly, we have
no transition, we realize that
the Torah interrupts to tell us
about the laws of kehuna, and begins
to tell us a story about kviyas
moadim, the fixing of the yom tovim.
Eileh moadei hashem tikreu osam
mikraei kodesh eileh hem moadai.
I mean, what does it got to
do with the previous chapter?
What's the answer?
The answer is that who was
who did fix the moadim?
To whom did the Torah entrust the kviyus moadim, to whom?
To the scholars, to the teachers,
to the Sanhedrin.
Asher tikre'u osam mikra'ei kodesh.
Who are they?
The kohanim.
That the Torah interrupts suddenly
because up to Parshas Moadim,
the Torah spoke about the kohen
who ministers to the Almighty.
Ki es lechem Elokav hu makriv.
Now the Torah tells us something else.
Yeah, but a kohen has
another job, another task.
His day is dedicated to another,
he's committed to something else,
namely, to scholarship and teaching.
And this is this identical is
kviyas moadim.
Does Yechezkel do it?
Mention it?
What does Yechezkel say?
Ve'es torosai ve'es chukosai bechol moadai
yishmoru, ve'es shabsosai yekadeishu.
The kvias hamoadim, moadai
veshabsosai ..., the kviyas moadim,
kviyas moadim is performed by the
Sanhedrin, by the scholars, by the
teachers, meir ha'umah, of the nation.
And that’s why it is the job of the kohen.
What else?
Something else was, please, something
else was assigned to the kohanim.
Namely, what?
Apparently to teach, apparently to
teach people on an abstract level,
just teach people theoretically,
theory is not good enough.
Whoever knows, what
should I say, the mood or
how yahadus wanted the people to act.
Of course, the first job is vishinantam
levanecha is to teach people.
But vishinantam levanecha does not mean
to teach them at an abstract level.
I mean, theory.
Vishinantam levanecha refers
also to teach people how to act.
And particularly the
principles of justice.
Velo saguru mipnei ish, don't
be afraid of anybody.
And you should remember
ki hamishpat l'Elokim hu,
judgment is up to the Almighty.
The fact is that the task
of the king, so the Rambam has
defined the task of the king
in a two is a twofold one.
First of all, to defend the land
of Yisrael, to defend simply.
If military action is
necessary, the king should do it.
And secondly, lishbor zroa reshaim,
to break the arm of the strong ones,
of the evildoers, to break their arm.
This is administration of justice.
And that's exactly what a
kohen is supposed to do.
And I want you to tell you,
I want you to understand.
We have many stories about
rabbonim of old, many stories.
Germany has its stories, Lithuania
has its stories and so forth
about rabbonim of old.
Is that stories do not revolve so
much about their scholarship.
Yes, we have many stories like that.
But this is not the main topic
which actually has motivated
us to tell stories.
But the main topic was the their sense,
their sensitive conscience, their sense
of justice that the Rov possessed.
For instance, there are many stories
about my grandfather and please, I
I'm not somehow trying to sell you
my grandfather.
First of all, he doesn't need to
be sold.
He doesn't need to be sold.
And secondly I'm not a Chassid, in the
sense that I tell stories in order
to glorify and magnify a person.
But my grandfather -- and
there are many stories
about his intellect.
He had a great intellect,
no doubt about it.
He had in my opinion he had one of
the strongest intellects that
lived at the turn of the century.
Not only among Jews,
but among goyim as well.
His intellect was tremendous.
Had he been a philosopher, he would have
changed our science in any field, he would
have changed in this particular discipline
upside down, completely, completely.
But I'll tell you frankly,
this commands respect,
But I'm not impressed by it.
He had an excellent head, he
was a genius, no doubt about it.
Abstract thinker, and revolutionary.
As far as interpretation of halacha is
concerned, he revolutionized their work.
My father once told me, I'm still
acting like a Chassid now; my father
has told me that if not for Reb Chaim,
there wouldn't have been a possibility
to teach modern young men with a
good training in science, halacha.
He made it possible to teach halacha,
that halacha can be taught to anyone,
even those who are advanced in logical
analysis and they will find that the
halacha is just as as exalted and
perhaps as abstract
as the most advanced mathematical logic or analytical logic.
But what I'm impressed,
I'm not impressed by that.
The gift was given to
him by The Almighty.
He presents some people He presents with a beautiful, precious gift,
but some people He
doesn't give anything.
This is not what
I .... I'm impressed by his heroism.
As far as social justice is concerned.
He was a real socialist,
a real one.
Not a Marxist socialist, but
a real socialist with a most
sensitive conscience and sensitive heart.
And his unlimited courage.
And I'm saying
it, in order to explain to you what the
Torah has demanded of the kohen.
I mean, I'll tell you, you know,
I have many stories.
He actually fought.
There was a, please,
I'm not trying to mislead you.
He once, there was a strike in Brisk.
Who could strike in Brisk?
They didn’t manufacture anything.
But one article they
manufactured, namely, matzah.
So those who worked in
the matzah shops went
out on strike.
So Reb Chaim supported them.
He collected money in order to
feed the people who were on strike.
It was Brisk, it was not
New York or Boston, 19, 1979, it was
Brisk in the turn of the century.
He almost lost his rabbanus.
But he did not deviate.
I'll give you another example.
The halacha is, the law is that if
rachmanah litzlan two people die on
the same day, so the woman has been
buried first and the man afterward.
The reason for it
is a different story.
So it happened in Brisk, it happened
that his most outstanding friend of
Reb Chaim, was a great scholar, was
a baal habayis, was a great scholar.
He actually was responsible for the fact
that Reb Chaim was elected rabbi of Brisk,
otherwise he wouldn't have been elected.
He died on a certain morning
and the same time, a poor woman
in the Brisker ghetto died.
And it was in the
winter, the day is short.
So the gabaiei Chevra Kadisha
figured out that ... as far as the
burial of the poor woman concerned,
it will be late, it would make no
difference whether she would be buried
at night or in the morning.
In Lithuania, they used to bury dead
at night, or in the morning, because
no one will come to the funeral anyway.
But the other, Reb Chaim Zalman Lipshitz,
this was his name.
I mean, he was the
pillar of the community.
In the morning, you have
a big send-off.
But in the evening, not
many people will come.
And they decided to bury him first
and to prepare him for burial first.
So Reb Chaim heard the story.
He sent a messenger to them, to
Chevra Kadisha, to stop preparing
Reb Chaim Zalman Lipshitz, but
to bury the poor woman first.
And if his burial will take
place at night, we can't help it.
So the Chevra Kadisha ignored his orders,
instructions, and continued to prepare
Reb Chaim Zalman Lipshitz for burial.
So Reb Chaim took his cane,
put on his coat, and told the
shammes -- the shammes told me, the
shammes who actually was present there
he told me this story -- told the shammes, come on.
And he went to the house of
Reb Chaim Zalman Lipshitz.
His greatest friend, his most outstanding friend,
who sacrifed himself actually,
in order to elect
Reb Chaim the rabbi of Brisk.
He went to the house and he
told the Chevra Kadisha to leave him
and to go to the
ghetto and bury the woman first.
This is his tremendous courage.
Not because people did criticize him, or
he lost a few of his supporters.
It is courage because he
acted against himself.
He himself mourned the
passing of his best friend.
He sacrificed his own
self, his own emotions.
After all he reciprocated this friendship.
Though he couldn't help it.
He was a prisoner of the law.
And a man has to sometimes have a lot
of courage in order to be a prisoner
of the law and to carry the law out.
I can tell you hundreds
of such stories.
There are no nissim,
there are no miracles.
But people, a great man, in
theory, a great man who has a
great intellect, should also have
a great heart and a sensitive heart.
And have particularly courage.
Velo saguru mipnei ish.
And that's exactly what the
Torah demanded from the kohen.
Does Yechezkel say it?
Ve'al riv eileh ya'amdu.
Wherever there is litigation,
wherever there is conflict,
wherever two people disagree with
each other, and the Rav has to
intervene, he's eileh ya'amdu,
he should stand, stand upright.
Not give in, not compromise, but
enforce and implement the law.
This is the second, the kohen is
a teacher, he is also his job is
to enforce, to administer justice.
And then, what else?
What is the third aspect
which the navi has formulated
as far as kehuna is concerned?
Not the navi, but actually this is
the Chumash, the Torah SheBichsav.
Yes?
[Inaudible]
I believe, I believe that the
third principle is to be found
in the haftarah of Tazria.
Who remembers the haftarah of Tazria?
Alright, read it?
What is the story?
The story there was Naaman.
There was Naaman who was a leper.
And he came to Eretz Yisrael
to Elisha, and Elisha healed
him, cured him of his leprosy.
And Geichazi wanted to see what
was his opinion that Elisha
should accept remuneration
a fee for for his miraculous job.
And Elisha refused to accept,
and Geichazi disobeying Elisha's
orders, ran after Naaman and got
some gifts from him, and he was
driven out by Elisha
from his house,
and Geichazi himself
became a leper.
This is the haftarah.
Correct?
What has it got to do with the parsha?
The parsha speaks about metzora, correct.
But what does the story of
Elisha got to do with the parsha,
with the parsha of Tazria?
Tazria is the parsha
of metzoraim, correct.
And the Haftarah is about a metzora who
was cured by a Jewish prophet, by Elisha.
Is this so important to
know, I mean, about Naaman?
What's important here
is the refusal on the
part of Elisha to accept remuneration
or a fee for his curing of Naaman.
Why did he refuse?
Because the main task of
the navi and the kohen is to
impress, to enhance the prestige,
of Yahadus among Jews
and non-Jews alike.
Naaman was very impressed by the
miraculous deed on the part of Elisha.
As a matter of fact, he was
ready, I mean, to convert, and he
asked Elisha about avodah zarah.
Because when he walks into the temple,
with the king of Aram, he has to bow
when the king bows before the idol.
So he asked Elisha whether
he's allowed to do so or not.
But Elisha considered the deed on
the part of Geichazi as wrong because
accepting of gifts
would undermine the high
prestige which, the high prestige
of respect which Elisha, I mean,
which Naaman had for Elisha.
The job of the kohen is like that of the
navi, lekadesh shem yisrael barabbim.
And that's exactly what Geichazi misunderstood.
And that is the book of Vayikra.
It's a book of the redemption,
of the final redemption,
it's also the book of kehuna.
It's not just a ministering kehuna.
Not just a cultic group which
engages in cultic activities.
No, it's more than that, by far more.
It's a group of teachers, it's a group
of administrators of justice, people with
a sensitive heart, sensitive mind, and
people who engage in chessed and don't
expect any compensation any remuneration
for their part, for their chessed.
And let me at the end in
conclusion say the following.
Our Torah has been exposed
to attacks since the days of
revelation at Mount Sinai.
The Torah was the target for
the most vicious attacks,
abuse and ridicule.
Maimonides in his letter to Teiman, to
the kehillah inTeiman, to the community
in Yemen, says that our enemies, our
antagonists, are planning to destroy us in
two ways, in a double manner: physically,
of course, Hitler tried it, just in our
time, as well as spiritually,
to erase Jewish identity.
And Maimonides says that
nevertheless, no matter how strong the
conspiracy is to destroy the Jew, he will
not succeed, they'll fail
in achieving this objective.
Maimonides in Iggeres Teiman.
He quotes a pasuk of Isaiah:
Kol kli alayich lo yitzlach,
any weapon formed against
thee will not be successful.
Vechol lashon takum itach lamishpat, and
every tongue which will sit in judgment
over thee, tarshi'i, you will condemn it.
It means that our antagonists will fail
as far as
both points are concerned.
They'll never destroy
the Jew physically, nor
will they make the Jew
forget his identity.
But even nowadays I have hopes that
the Jew, I mean, there was in 1945
after the Holocaust, I mean, when
became known to the world the Jew, I
actually, not I I mustn't say I had
great doubts, chas veshalom, but I
was very pessimistic, very sad about
the prospects of the Jew to survive.
Now somehow, of course, a big
role is played by the Medinas Yisrael.
It has a tremendous
role. It is somehow the symbol of
indestructibility of
the Jew, spiritually as
well as physically.
It's an old story, Maimonides did
not say anything new, and we all
hope that the tongue which sits in
judgment over us as well as
the weapon which our enemies
forge against us will fail.
However, if there is a book in the whole
Torah ..., there is no other book which
will ... by our antagonists as the book of
Leviticus, of the the code of the priests.
Since the days, what should I say,
of ... Christianity,
namely ... Chazal, There was
an organized attack against kehuna and
the book of kehuna, namely,
Sefer Vayikra.
...even among bible critics, when they
come to Sefer Vayikra, so they enjoy it,
they enjoy the opportunity very
much, the opportunity to abuse and
to ridicule and to destroy with their
cynicism, with sarcasm Sefer Vayikra
of Chamishah Chumshei Torah.
Because by destroying Vayikra, the
book of kehuna, they destroy kehuna.
By destroying kehuna, they
destroy the Beis Hamikdash.
By destroying the Beis Hamikdash, they
destroy all the hopes which we have
to come back into the Beis Hamikdash.
By destroying the Beis Hamikdash and our
hopes for Moshiach, they destroy also,
they destroy also the Jewish identity.
The people to whom the land was promised
are not the Jews, but some other people,
and I don't have to tell it to you.
And how did we react to our
enemies and antagonists in
this regard how did we react?
What did we do
throughout the ages?
We have a funny method how to
react to such attacks, vicious
attacks, to false accusations, to
misinterpretation and to lying.
We have a funny approach to it.
The Ramban in his letter, you
know, you all know the phrase.
Let me paraphrase the Ramban.
The Ramban in his letter upon his
arrival in Eretz Yisrael, this is the
last letter we have from him, we don't
know where he disappeared, writes to
the son about the desolation and the
churban which prevails in Eretz Yisrael.
And ... is his famous statement.
Kol hakadosh beyoser chorev beyoser.
Whatever is the most most
holy to us is most desolate.
And I can say this was the approach
of the Jew to all attacks on
the part of his enemies.
Kol mah shemul'ag beyoser, anything
which is most ridiculed, ridiculed the
most, any other spiritual value or Jewish
institution which is the most abused,
abused the most, is chaviv aleinu beyoser,
is dear and we cherish it the more.
Interesting is that Vayikra was chosen
to be read between Pesach and Shavuos.
This is the Sefer Vayikra.
Shemini is the first
Shabbos after Vayikra.
And before
we are ready to celebrate Shavuos, we
have to read the tochacha in Bechukosai,
we need to read not only the tochacha
but the Parshas Bamidbar as well.
And it means that when you go
to Har Sinai on Shavuos, we have
the whole Torah in our hand.
But in particular, we have Sefer Vayikra.
And it's an old minhag, it's mentioned in
Medrash, that you start with a child to
start teaching the child Sefer Vayikra.
This is the book, it's the book of kehuna.
And every Jew should act as
if he were a kohen.
After all, kehuna was not given to
a single person, to a single tribe.
Vihyisem li mamleches kohanim vegoy
kadosh, you'll be a kingdom of kohanim.
Every Jew can become a kohen.
How can he become a kohen?
By teaching, by administering
justice and by engaging in chessed.
A mekadesh shem Shamayim.
That's all.